el Primer Ministro canadiense de Justin
trudo se pronunció a primeras horas de
la tarde fue una locución que era muy
esperada pero él tenía que seguir
algunas medidas de protocolo Y tuvo que
esperar a que fuera primero la
gobernadora general que es la
representante de la reina aquí en Canadá
y después de la locución de ella él Pudo
finalmente dirigirse al pueblo
canadiense lo hizo de una manera
bastante informal con un discurso que
fue redactado de su propia mano fueron
sus palabras las que él quiso dar para
honrar a la reina en un momento tan
sensible y tan doloroso que inquieta y
afecta a todo el pueblo canadiense entre
las palabras del Primer Ministro él dijo
que la mayoría de los canadienses no
había conocido otra soberana que la
reina Elizabeth Isabel segunda también
dijo que la describió como una persona
inquieta curiosa y muy alegre y
recordemos que el Primer Ministro de la
conoce desde muy muy pequeño cuando
él la pudo visitar la pudo conocer
cuando era el hijo del entonces Primer
Ministro Pierre helio crudo Así que
también le dedicó unas palabras de
agradecimiento por todos los consejos
que ella le había dado a lo largo de su
carrera fueron 70 años en los cuales
marcó la historia de Canadá de muchas
maneras y también 23 giras reales que la
reina realizó a lo largo del país de
Canadá Carolina y entre tanto cómo están
los ánimos en el país en las actitudes
ciudadanas en torno a la posibilidad de
seguir estando cobijados por la
monarquía o las voces que se le van en
favor de ser una república
por los momentos toda la discusión se ha
centrado en cómo vamos a vivir este
momento de luto no se han hecho los
anuncios oficiales de la forma como se
va a celebrar específicamente porque hay
muchas medidas de protocolo a realizarse
pero sin duda tiene muchas discusiones
para el país canadiense quiero decirles
también que hoy la provincia de Quebec
está en este momento prepararse
preparando preparación elecciones
provinciales decidió suspender por hoy
la campaña electoral y poner todas las
banderas en todos los edificios de esta
provincia a media asta bueno en
conmemoración de todo esto que está
ocurriendo y en honor a el legado que
nos deja la Reina Isabel II